>> Dana: DATA SHOWS ARKANSAS IS
AMONG THE BOTTOM 10 STATES IN
VACCINATION RATES.
49% OF RESIDENTS FULLY
VACCINATED.
GOVERNOR HUTCHISON IS URGING
EVERYONE TO GET THEIR SHOTS BUT
SAYS ENFORCING A MANDATE IS NOT
THE ANSWER.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THE NEW
VARIANT?
HAVE YOU HEARD ANYTHING FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON WHAT
YOU AS A GOVERNOR SHOULD BE
CONSIDERING?
>> WE ARE STILL WAITING FOR
MORE INFORMATION, BUT CLEARLY
WE ARE USED TO DEALING WITH NEW
VARIANTS.
WE HAVE THE DELTA VARIANT HIT
US VERY HARD HERE IN ARKANSAS.
WE WERE ONE OF THE FIRST STATES
AND FROM WHAT WE SEE IN THE
EARLY INFORMATION, THE OMICRON
VARIANT MIGHT BE MORE
CONTAGIOUS BUT THERE IS NOT ANY
INDICATION THAT IT IS AS SEVERE
AS EVEN THE DELTA VARIANT.
WE'RE WAITING ON MORE
INFORMATION BUT IN THE
MEANTIME, WE ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THIS TO INCREASE
OUR VACCINATIONS IN ARKANSAS.
I CONTINUE TO PUSH THOSE AND WE
SHOULD NOT BE UNSTEADY IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT.
WE NEED TO WAIT FOR MORE
INFORMATION, NOT PANIC.
OUR EMERGENCY IN ARKANSAS ENDED
SOME TIME AGO.
WE'RE MANAGING THE CORONAVIRUS
HERE.
WE WANT TO HANDLE NEW VARIANT
THAT COMES IN WITH INCREASED
VACCINATION RATES.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS
YOU'LL HEAR FROM THE PRESIDENT
SPEAKING ABOUT THE NEW VARIANT
AND OTHER ISSUES IN REGARD TO
COVID.
THEY SAY MANDATES WORKED.
LOOK AT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THE MANDATE FOR WORKERS THEY
ARE UP IN THE MID-90s IN TERMS
OF TAKE-UP RATES FOR VACCINES
BUT YOU THINK THAT THE MANDATE
FOR YOU HAS ACTUALLY MADE IT
MORE DIFFICULT TO CONVINCE
PEOPLE TO GET THE VACCINE.
>> I DO.
PEOPLE BUCK UP.
THEY OFFER MORE RESISTANCE IF
THE GOVERNMENT IS TELLING THEM
THIS IS WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO.
WE ARE MAKING GREAT PROGRESS
THROUGH MEDICAL INFORMATION,
TRUSTED ADVISORS.
I HAD COMMUNITY TOWN HALL
MEETINGS AND WE GRADUALLY
INCREASED THE VACCINATION RATE
AND WE CONTINUE TO DO IT.
IT IS HARDER WHENEVER YOU HAVE
THE DEBATE ABOUT THE MANDATES
AND SO WE OPPOSE A FEDERAL
MANDATE.
THE FIRST TIME IN HISTORY THEY
HAVE HAD THIS HEAVY FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT COME IN AND TELL THE
STATES WHAT TO DO.
EVERY STATE MIGHT BE DIFFERENT.
FOR ARKANSAS, WE ARE USING
EDUCATION, COMMON SENSE, AND
DRIVING THOSE NUMBERS UP AND
PEOPLE TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
WHENEVER YOU SEE THE RISK, THAT
INCREASES OUR VACCINATION RATE.
I THINK